morning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
[Music]
advised welcome to LED live this is the
show where we use the Light of Christ to
expose the darkness found in media and
our culture today I'm really excited
about the topic we have but before we
get into that I actually have something
for you guys Co gift thing to get the
conversation going I got some gummies
ooh C are they vegan is one of them po
are actually awesome they are wait wait
but before before you you eat some
especially you Scotty cuz you you made
mention that you want to cut back on
some sweets I want you to keep in mind
this fact in the
Philippines a child was traded for just
s lbs of candy oh my can you believe
that it's crazy wow in the Philippines
it's illegal to get married under the
age of 18 but in the more remote age
areas this still happens like under the
radar so this di for this child to get
married was just 7 pounds of candy like
this is a real thing and this is
happening worldwide including the United
States wow and so it is for that reason
that I'm thrilled to have Tom Evans here
with us thank you so much for coming on
the show thank you Tom is the CEO of
child impact International and so he's
here to really give us a a reality check
so to speak about child exploitation and
to provide tips as to how we can really
fulfill our calling as Christians to
protect the least of these so thank you
again Tom for accepting the invitation
I'm excited for what you have to share
yeah thank you it's good to be here so
um as we get started here can you tell
us what is it exactly that you do and
what got you into this what got you
started sure so child impact actually
started 57 years ago it's a long time
ago before I was born uh just but uh
really empowering children through
education and so child sponsorship you
know which we see you know we're
familiar with that concept of helping a
child who can afford to go to school to
be able to do that so we still are
involved with child sponsorship you know
around 4,500 children that we sponsor
right now but about 10 years ago we got
involved in fighting human trafficking
and our first project was in India and
so as I became involved with child
impact about 3 years ago uh this was a
space that I really felt we needed to
speak into more and to take more uh
involvement with and so that's what
we've been doing and so we've now grown
that to about 20 projects that directly
fight human trafficking wow wow wow you
you hear about a lot in in our country
um every time I fly through Atlanta they
always have something blaring on the on
the speaker you know if you see anything
you know call this number or whatever
like that in terms of um worldwide I
know this stuff happens and you often
see it in these other countries but this
goes on here in our own
it does and you know kudos to Atlanta
for drawing attention to it I fly
through there all the time as well and I
haven't heard that in other
airports um but it's certainly something
that they've taken seriously um but in
terms of the engagement with the US when
it comes to human trafficking um we're
2% of What's Done globally so about two
out of every five trafficked individuals
are in India um so we're only 2% in
terms of actual trafficking victims but
we are a major player when it comes to
funding human trafficking so that's
where the US has been involved
unfortunately and so most of the victims
are across other borders but we we are
involved in other ways consumers yeah
you got to wonder if it's proportional
though the amount of people in India
versus the exploitation and then the
United States where smaller population
2% might be you know big in terms of the
proportions actually India just blows us
out of the water yeah yeah that's where
that's where the big challenge is and
the average price of a slave today is
$90 how much $90 you mean for the entire
like globally nobody mean like you're
purchasing them that's not just like a
onetime use that's like you own this
person for $90 wow that's crazy so and
of course you know with drug use you
know drugs are used up and then people
go back and have to get another one but
a girl can be used over and over again
or or a boy in some cases yeah I I
remember um I saw sound of Freedom
recently and and they had mentioned I
think in that one how many times they
were used yeah and it's just just
mindboggling yeah so we're working in
the largest what's been called the
largest brothel in the world in doaa in
Bangladesh some say it's number rank
number four now but there's 1 1600
prostitutes there in that um that slum
you know brothel area and so customers
come in every day multiple customers per
woman the average age of a girl that
goes to that um brothel is 14 years old
and again it's the situation where it's
legal after 18 or 18 or older but it's
illegal younger but nevertheless that's
what what is happening demand is there
and so we have a safe house that is
nearby there that we've just that's a
new project for us wow well let me ask
you this before we get back to how you
even got starred into this because this
is a lot um let's let's lay a ground a
foundation when it comes to definitions
when someone says something like human
trafficking child trafficking is it kind
is it only in a sexual sense or what how
other how else can it be presented yeah
so in terms of the income from Human
Trafficking $150 billion business almost
a hundred billion dollar of that is the
sex trafficking but you know that's the
most well-known but in terms of volume
and of types of trafficking that's a
smaller percentage because labor
trafficking uh forc child marriage uh
these are things that are included in
that concept of human trafficking but
probably the biggest is that anytime
someone under the age of 18 is involved
in sex work it is considered to be human
trafficking so that's the biggest in
terms of how the US is engaged with the
sex trafficking side of things because
you go to a site like only fans and
that's where you know somebody can
become their own porn star and a third
of the individuals that are featured
there are underage so that's how America
is contributing one of the major ways
America is contributing to human
trafficking you're saying on only on
only fans there's adult content being
presented by underage people yeah about
a third of how does that happen legally
in America it shouldn't be this was a
study done out of England where they
looked at who is presenting themselves
on the site and they say one3 or
underage and I mean there's there's just
probably not the manpower to be able to
we just had a show about AI I know
that's where this is this is one of
those uses that I think AI is very
appropriate in in in a setting you know
if it can tell you you have melanoma on
your skin right can I not tell you your
age basically like hey this person
flagged is looks awfully young yeah yeah
I mean they can put you in Facebook jail
or whatever for saying you're mad at gas
prices or whatever it is like people get
put in there all the time but yet all
this stuff is happening that you could
really put that technology to good use
for and crazy and like you said like we
are big consumers here in the United
States so I mean this goes all the way
to the tippy top right we're talking
politicians and people that are actually
the ones that can get you in trouble are
protecting that
system yeah epsteins and all them yeah
and we see we see that globally as well
when our first project started in India
10 years ago our partner there was
knocking down doors of brothel and
working with the police to catch the
perpetrators the challeng is when they
looked at the registers in these brothel
it was government leaders and police
officers that were there and so yeah the
corruption you know kind of allows this
to perpetuated yeah so that's the
challenge wow okay so you made mention
of only fans um that's in the in the
digital world so to speak what about
instances of like uh being kidnapped or
or or those things is that present at
all in well I shouldn't I shouldn't say
if it's present at all we know it is
yeah um but what are the statistics on
that in this country versus other other
places yeah I would say it's a it's a
small percentage of the human
trafficking component uh in the United
States it's um you know you have
situations like runaways being
approached within 48 Hours by a
trafficker so certainly that would be
somebody who's taken but you know
there's the approach of a Romeo pimp of
somebody who appears to be a romantic
partner and then shifts and traffic so
those are more common than somebody just
being snatched off the streets uh drug
addiction can cause somebody to get into
the um you know into the trafficking
world all right the exchange is there
yeah so those are some of the more
common ways but of course people do get
taken and we know there's been a
disappearance at the border of of many
children and so that does happen um we
ran into this with the Ukraine crisis uh
with the war there especially at the
beginning things were not monitored well
at the borders and girls and women would
be picked up and then delivered they
don't know where and so our partners on
the ground were saying that this was a
major issue it got remedied further into
uh things happening but when immediately
there's a rush to leave the country
those are the vulnerable times and
that's why like the the southern border
is a very vulnerable place for
trafficking to happen because of the the
situations of people coming over here
without a place to stay not knowing what
they're going to be doing and
traffickers step into those
vulnerabilities wow well it's easy to
hear all this and get overwhelmed and
unfortunately just stop and like I don't
know what to do so what after hearing
all of this information what actually
got you active and involved into this
what is your story and beginning in
child impact
sure my wife and I have uh really felt a
life calling to do something to help the
most vulnerable when we were dating my
wife said she want to have 10 kids and
sign me up sh yeah I was like well um
this can't be true um but uh she didn't
mean that we would biologically have our
own 10 children that we gave birth to
but that adoption would be be part of
our journey and you know maybe I was a
little slower than her to come on board
with that but you know the more you look
at it and think about why we're in this
world and you we're really placed here
to make a difference it's like yeah we
should be involved in that way so I have
a picture here of one of the two boys uh
that we adopted um these boys were from
an orphanage in laia so this is the same
boy here um he has an older brother but
I share his photo because um he ended up
passing away away from
leukemia and so as we went on that
Journey you know just the the pain that
he was going through knowing that we
could be his family we could be you know
by his side rather than in a lone
situation um he always wanted to give
back and wanted to grow up and adopt
himself because he'd been adopted and so
what he doesn't know um because he
passed away a little over years ago is
that we have these girlss now joining
our family wow so we are at the tail end
of our adoption Journey with these two
girls so huge blessing so that was part
of our own Journey so I just have a
couple sites up here that I wanted to
share for individuals that may have an
interest in adopting internationally um
there are lots of grants available we
always thought that the finances were a
huge barrier the paperwork's the barrier
if you can do the paperwork you can get
the money and so I'm a paperwork Guru
now um so
anyway that's that's part of the
challenge there but they also have an
opportunity to host an orphan for a
summer or for Christmas and so that's
how we originally met the two boys these
two girls are from Bulgaria they have a
gypsy background are they related or
there sisters as far as we know um we
get a certain amount of information up
front we really feel like God led us to
these two particular girls and we've had
video calls and anyway we're excited in
the next couple of months we're going to
go over and have our first inperson
awesome connection then a few months
after that we get bring them home so
it's a long journey but it's a huge
blessing and so I recognize that not
everybody can adopt but everybody can
sponsor a child you know and give them
an opportunity for an education you
change a world for that child and so
that tie between our personal journey
and the work of child impact um is quite
significant that's wonderful amen and I
want to commend you because what you're
doing at home is matching the initiative
that you're a part of um and so when
comes to what you're doing within the
ministry what does that look like
internationally especially because
what're what we're going through here
the the stipulations the limitations
that are ha may or may not be um in on a
global scale internationally so how does
that look like from an organizational
standpoint so i' I'd say globally
there's one word and that's the word
poverty uh and that's it's it's a very
different list of vulnerabilities when
you look at globally versus domestically
and so this is something that we really
feel we need to step into because there
are solutions and so you know there's
cases that we come across and it's like
you know we actually can do something we
can actually step into this space and
save this child um and so that's very
rewarding to know that you can actually
make a difference and so maybe I can
share just of how some of these
vulnerabilities are a little bit
different um we found you know girls
many times will say can I become a
sacrifice so that my family can survive
and that's how they get into the
trafficking because they're like I'll
take the brunt hit of it so that you
don't have to yeah so wow so there's got
to be salvation for for these people I
mean that's like that's like Jesus right
there right oh I mean it's it's
incredible and it's not something they
want to do so when they're rescued from
it they're very happy to be free from it
they don't want to go back to the even
though it's you know guaranteed income
they don't they don't want that and so
how does that how does their family
actually benefit is the person who's
trafficking this girl now going to send
money to their family I mean can you
even trust that well the typical
situation is that that that we're
engaged with is a truck driver will you
know this girl's out trying to sell
vegetables by the roadway and the truck
driver a truck driver will approach her
and say look you know I'm not interested
the vegetables but it's worth this much
I'll give you three I'll give you $5
it's about equivalent to what they'll
get and so they end up sleeping with the
truck driver and they have money then
that they can take home to their family
okay so she does it willingly just yeah
enticed to it because of the money well
and and we look at it and say well you
know we're so used to options in America
and for for many of them and and I could
share stories from different countries
it's like they don't see any option in
front of them it's either do this or
die and so that's that's the kind of
thing they're facing and so they choose
to sacrifice themselves and then you
have cases where they're like there is a
wage earner for the family and they're
just barely surviving but something
happens to the wage owner we I met a man
who pulled down his FR his pants in
front of me and showed me scars on his
leg where he'd been attacked by a
crocodile so he'd been out fishing to
support his family walked two hours to
do that now he can't walk to to fish to
support his family so the daughter ends
up trafficked wow or someone has a
stroke yeah it's just there's so many
different things that can happen it's so
wild when you hear these kind of stories
because we're so disconnected from our
modern setting you know what I mean like
we're not walking to go get a candy or
something to eat you know what I mean
it's it's it's like a whole another
world and and and then you just kind of
understand you understand when you when
you hear those stories and you go yeah
of course anybody would do that in that
situation you know yeah we have a crazy
experience that we that we came across
where we'd rescued a girl so she was at
our school um she was safe from the
trafficking scenario but she was really
distressed and it was because her mom
was about be ready to be thrown in jail
jail why her dad had run up a debt the
debt collectors wanted the daughter in
exchange for the debt wow so the mother
refused the dad took off and so now the
mom is on the hook for the debt oh my
and so you know the mom has no way to
pay this and now they're saying we don't
want only just the one daughter we want
their second daughter as well in payment
for this debt she said I'm not going to
do it well then you get to go to jail
and so we checked out her story found
out she was walking two hours to work to
braid hair and we we got her a bike our
partner there presented that to her and
then we found out her debt was $411
oh us yeah just destroying her
life wow yeah so is that an ongoing
thing right now or is it oh we yeah we
provided the funds so now now both
daughters are in our school we built a
dormatory for 100 rescue girls this is
in Zambia and you know they're paying
students want to get in but that was
funded by donors for rescue girls what
we make in a couple of days their whole
life she'd be in jail where where's that
put her daughters you know and being
marketed by these two by these gentlemen
that the debt was owed wow and and I'm
sure these stories are so many it's like
you feel like you're throwing a pebble
into the ocean we we've had
conversations about homelessness on the
show before and the St the statistic
came up that it only takes a couple of
months for someone to be on the street
for their mental health to significantly
decline so in the cases where um it's a
child
exploitation situation that may be a
little bit more complicated how much
convincing on the child of on the side
of child impact does it take to um get
this person to leave that world or
receive help or or go into a different
lifestyle that is more safe or is it
just like a flip switch yes get me out
of here please please please yeah so a
parent put it uh put it this way to us
they said our girls used to worry about
food and survival now they can chase
their dreams amen and so really this is
not something and when you look at the
vulnerabilities the difference in the
vulnerabilities it's clear that if
poverty is the main driver and a
different option comes then they're
going to step into that so we have an
example from the the slums in India it's
called the visic slum where we run a
tailoring project for women who are in
prostitution and we also have a
preschool there for their children and
so these women as they register they all
I mean we get more registration than we
have spaces and so we run two uh classes
a year run for several months they've
then develop a skill that they can find
employment with or that they can run
their own business but the women are
telling us since we started working in
that slum 5 years ago the prostitution
has dropped by 50% oh wow so we want to
see that drop to zero but you know when
when I can meet a child or a young adult
there who was sponsored who did have a
sponsor to go to school and she's a
nurse in a nearby hospital
she didn't have to choose prostitution Y
and that's that's where it feels like a
pebble being thrown in the ocean but
actually when you sit down and you
really realize it's just flipping one it
can flip 10 it can flip you know and
then just exponentially grow from there
beautiful so we have a girl that is in a
secret project we have a couple secret
projects that we can't record on video
we can't publish our
magazine but um she her parents had
passed away in fact her mom had been
killed by a a car bomber and so kind of
very extreme situation here uh her
grandfather started selling her body to
make money and so this girl her
statement was that she wished that
someday somebody would switch on the
light for her so that's happened now
she's in a safe house she's safe she has
a bright future there's a lot of
recovery as you're referring to there's
really the trauma that someone goes
through in this experience takes a while
to recover from but we found the first
step is to get them in a safe place
where they're no longer living with fear
so there's never any skepticism with you
guys like well how can I trust you or I
mean do you run into that we have to
follow proper processes so we work with
government officials we work with Social
Services uh there's a girl that we took
off the streets in kangoma Tanzania and
you could appear like you're a
trafficker if you just this girl just
disappears all of a sudden right the
very thing we're trying to save her from
we could be you know perceived as
perpetuating so we went to the local
government leader in that area and
received a legal um signed document that
gave us the ability to place her in our
school wow in a safe place and we're
concerned so much that she falls back
into that situation that she was in and
this was a girl that was not trafficked
as far as we know she was just in
extreme poverty but men were trying to
take advantage of her and she's being
protected by a group of boys wow so
they're all living out on the street so
we're saying this is not a place for
this girl and it really think speaks to
us that our our job and I and I speak to
men in this is to protect not to exploit
right and I think so many of these girls
are exploited by men and yet our job is
the exact opposite we're called to
protect and look out for the vulnerable
and so now she is in a safe place but uh
her mom is mentally unwell and locks her
out of the house at night and so that's
why she's out on the streets but the mom
loves her daughter in her own broken her
own Brokenness and the daughter misses
her mom so we allow the mom to come
visit out on the campus of the school
but we know sending the girl back
there it's not a good situation you know
people all around the house are drunk
she's just it's it's just an invit she's
12 years old and we just know that any
moment you know things will tip for her
in the wrong direction but you know this
was a case where we saw a situation and
we said you know we can make a
difference for that girl so it's like
that one at a time
yeah beautiful sounds like child impact
is in the business of creating options
so people can choose better ones
wonderful okay what what other
vulnerabilities uh do you come and and
face do we we talked about most of those
but how would a a fake job offer okay
what's an example of that that is
actually the number one tactic used by
traffickers globally so we have a case
this is in Tanzania girls living along
the
border they get to a certain age
and the families you know may have many
children have a hard time you know
supporting all the kids once that girl's
12 13 14 years old it's like you can
make it on your own now which is hard
for us to imagine here but she basically
has two options at that point one is to
get married as a child
bride and the other one is to accept a
job offer and unfortunately those job
offers many of them are fake fake offers
as a domestic worker and so the parents
are hopeful that maybe this is you know
the big City she can get a job can send
money back maybe to support the family
but most of the time that's a front for
human trafficking and so you look at a
country like Tanzania that takes human
trafficking seriously that wants to
arrest perpetrators that wants to send
girls that are being trafficked through
Tanzania often down to South Africa but
also through zanen bar they're being
trafficked to the Middle East and Europe
they want to stop that and so they're
very proactive active in that sense but
it still happens but if they if they're
able to find a vehicle that's
transporting girls these girls are from
other countries a lot of times they will
send them back to the country they came
from but we have a rescue scenario there
uh in country for Tanzanian girls that
are at risk for trafficking and we work
with government officials police
officers and so on to identify who those
girls are and then we bring them into
our um we're building a dorm for those
girls now that reminds me of a question
that I had you said you work with
government officials and and police
officers and law enforcement which is
fantastic um has it always been a great
experience working with them since earli
in the program we were talking about the
number of politicians that are involved
in in this
exploitation you know we've I I believe
we've been blessed with working with the
right ones amen um in Colombia for
example um when our team shows up at one
of the projects there the police are
there to escort us to meet us when we
get off the plane this is the only place
this is happening so I you know it
sounds amazing but it what happened in
Colombia is because of the work we're
doing with indigenous children who are
very uh much at risk for trafficking
it's garnered the attention of
government officials and even the
president of the country is aware of our
project and wants to visit but within a
few weeks of starting this project few
months now close to 100 child abusers
have been arrested which is phenomenal
and so obviously those those people
aren't happy right and so there's a you
know going settle the score yeah the
local police officers are very much
Vigilant and supportive of the project
we have there to make S make sure that
we're safe and our partners are safe wow
awesome I've been sitting here looking
at this chain what what is this A visual
representation of sure do you see one
one link that's a different color right
yeah so there's 100 links on this chain
and this one link represents that only
one individual that's trafficked out of
100 will ever escape m
wow so really uh you know the movie
sound of freedom and I've got a a
picture of it right here but um I don't
know if you remember the scene where two
agents are talking with each other one
was the experienced agent Tim Balor
represented there and the other was
somebody new and and he asked Tim
Ballard you know how effective have you
been in your fight against human
trafficking and he mentioned some number
over 200 perpetrators that have been
arrested and then the new guy asked well
but how many children have you actually
set
free there was
silence and then he finally said most of
them are across International borders
and that's what really led to the whole
the whole story of trying to actually
free some children and you know based on
a true story out of Colombia
incidentally and so when I saw that
we're already working in Colombia and we
could really resonate with parts of that
story and the scenes depicted there but
yeah it's once and this is like the this
the dadea brothel in Bangladesh the
women that run that if we go in there we
just break in and we take kids out I
mean we are in a you know a government
you know crisis there that's happening
by by taking that kind of approach so we
have to wisely approach it and so our
partner there talked with the eight
women that run this brothel and said
look will you give us some of your
younger client you know Cent women that
you know you're you're trafficking here
12 13 14 year olds and their answer was
no and so you know these you know
14-year-olds coming in as the average
age and so they're already making a lot
of money off of these younger girls
probably more than from the older women
that are being trafficked there and so
they did say to us that they would allow
us to take their younger siblings so
that gives us the 10 11 12 year olds but
when you think about a girl like that
growing up in a brothel you know that's
where she's headed yeah and so we didn't
find that yeah to get that one out is
really challenging but we can prevent it
and so yes we have cases where we're
able to pull girls directly out of
trafficking
situations but you know knowing that
that's where someone's headed and being
able to prevent it is the more likely
approach and are the authorities aware
of these 14-year-olds that are part of
these if it's a large brothel and lots
of people know about it I mean what what
are they doing about it yes certainly
and I I haven't gone deep enough with
that particular project but yeah
certainly there's awareness you know
like the Philippines to know that child
marriage is a is happening these remote
Villages but enforcement is is a
challenge um and there's such a demand
for it as well and so you know you take
like FGM female genital mutilation in a
country like Kenya um it's illegal and
so the age of that happening is is
driven down to lower and lower ages
trying to prevent detection and so our
partner there will only take girls if
there's an actual court case oh wow
because there's you know there's abuses
on the other side of that to say hey
we're rescuing from FGM and it may be a
girl just trying to you know trying to
find a place to stay and go to school
and parents kind of taking advantage of
that but when there's an actual court
case that's been filed against a
perpetrator that's when our partner says
okay we can take that girl in so yeah
there's there's complications with the
work and we need to make sure these are
legitimate cases that we're actually
when we talk about rescue it's a real
rescue uh that's happening because there
are a lot of of different um situations
where people are not being honest with
the situation my family um we took a
actually huge family on my wife's side
of the family um Christmas
vacation and to kiato which is over
there in Kenya and it's a lot of the
girls that they've rescued from the fjm
and they um
um we're building dorms through maratha
and so you know there are some ways that
people can get involved um not everybody
can go on a trip but you certainly can
help fund trips you you certainly can go
on a mission trip and work in
environments like this that are helping
you know give resources to being able to
pull these people out and I I think it's
important I think we all need to Rally
together and help these poor kids out
they're beautiful children absolutely
well the sound of freedom is a movie
that like shook this nation right and
there are also like documentaries U the
invisible hands I don't know if you
you've heard of that one or stolen
childhoods I was seven or eight years
old when I went to work in people's
homes my parents were poor and did not
see the value of educating
[Music]
me I saw the children go to school and
had a hidden wish to go with them
I saw the children being carefree and
playing with each other and making
noise I felt that I should be like them
and make noise as
[Music]
well for
246 million
children life is nothing but
work for the ones that you've seen
especially since you have personal
experience in this work how accurate are
these portrayals and then to what degree
do these films actually accomplish real
change in our society when it's talking
about people getting involved that's a
great question I I would say for sure
the sound of Freedom represented a
reality um that we're aware of and
working in Colombia and so you know in
Colombia 200,000 girls a year are abused
35,000 of those are in commercial sexual
exploitation so in that movie just over
100 children were rescued and so you
know it's again you know the chain here
with you know one out of a hundred so
that's a small number but you you make a
world of difference for that child but I
I think the movies you know the one that
uh really grabbed me I think that was it
was almost verbatim of what we
experience in India is a movie called
sold and it really shows how girls are
enticed from other countries so many
times a country won't traffic their own
so so I think about our secret projects
we have two of them and the second one
we've opened they're trafficking girls
from the first location that we're at
this a secret project W and so we're
rescuing from the same country in two
different countries oh wow and so super
challenging there but this movie sold um
it it's a combination of multiple true
stories so kind of taking a theme of the
kind of things that happen with
trafficking and you see a very young
girl um parents in poverty somebody
coming that looks like they're a
professional saying look I can get a job
for your girl in in in India and giving
them parents a sum of money then showing
how they drugged her and you know forced
her into you know being raped really and
you know how she ultimately escaped but
just you see so many elements of things
we're aware of really happening there um
one of the another really good movie
that's based out of the US is called
Priceless and the music group for king
and country um they actually are in that
movie as as actors and actress and so on
and so uh that one's very well done as
well so again those give us a
picture what I always say though is most
of what these movies do for us is all
they do is raise
awareness and awareness is only a first
step in a change process so
unfortunately I get I get a little
frustrated because I look and say oh
there's a lot of people that know about
it they're aware of it but relatively
few who do anything about it right and
so that's that's the real challenge is
how do you how do you go from awareness
to
action I think I think in our world um
we we talk about this on our show a lot
I think it's time for all Hands-On deck
I really do think we're in the final
stages of Earth's history here and when
you get to heaven if you're wanting to
go there or planning to go there or
whatever right I think the regret you're
going to feel looking back on is did I
do enough that's right every single one
of us can do something yeah like whether
it's with financial or tiny little bits
of help or or whatever you know it's
like not everybody can do the work but
you certainly are working and you know
it's like we live in such a
luxurious you know country that you know
we spend money like it's nothing five
bucks here for a hot drink five bucks
here for this or that right if you just
denied yourself for five bucks and
everybody were to do that and help we
could some serious help into these
organizations including prevention you
know they're not getting started
starting the prevention within the home
and then that branching out to the
community and then at large but how do
you make it practical what does
practical prevention look like what does
getting involved look like for someone
who's just like that was a lot of
information there are a lot of different
options what could I do yeah I I really
point to two things uh when I share I
share a lot in local churches um you
know I'm happy to take our team we have
people that can preach in local churches
and share this particular the afternoon
we'll do an afternoon program as well so
where we talk about what are the
vulnerabilities how can we be aware but
then what's the next step and so the
most practical in America and the
simplest one in terms of making a direct
impact right away is to not be involved
in pornography amen is really that's
funding you know so you look at a site
like only fans with a third underage and
the the money that goes into this you
know $99 billion business of sex
trafficking um America is we're on the
hook for that we're very responsible for
our decisions for our behaviors that
fuel the human trafficking that happens
globally so that's a first step it's a
very practical step either if somebody's
personally involved to figure out how to
break free from that or to spread the
word to those that you know that we may
be aware of that are involved in this
world and say look you're helping to
fund human trafficking by these
decisions so that's a first step the
other one is to partner with an
organization like child impact in our
rescue projects so we call this
operation child rescue we have a special
fund that we use for these projects we
have 20 projects I would say on average
are projects to run over a year cost
$50,000 a project so that's not a small
amount of money and so you know somebody
who can give a few dollars a month but
do it on a monthly basis that adds up
when you begin to put a lot of those
together and that's what we're really
looking to do and so we call individuals
who partner with us monthly monthly
they're part of the rescue party amen
and so they're going on these rescue
missions with us amen and so we give
updates monthly to that group to that
rescue party and uh that's a way that we
can make sure that you know we we don't
want to start a project and then say oh
now we can't fund it for next year right
these are girls boys lives that are at
risk and so we want to make sure that
they can stay in a safe place and they
can really have a vision for their life
um beyond the trauma that they've been
through can you imagine meeting these
people in heaven and being like you know
you gave a little bit of money and I'm
literally here because of you giving me
this money yeah you cancelled your
Netflix and your Disney plus and gave it
to this so much better I mean so I I
have one just real quick this girl in
the orange skirt there um I was
preaching my wife's there in the next to
her um but I was preaching and these are
some of the girls in Zambia that uh have
moved into this Hunter girl d Ator but I
was approached by the girl in the orange
skirt and this group of girls after I
preached and she was very
emotional and she said I just want to
thank child impact for changing our
lives and she was in tears wow I mean
imagine that how I felt about that and
then she said we've had really tough
lives I wow and I was like wow that is
super powerful because all those girls
standing right there their lives have
been completely changed wow
you know I I I wonder if you literally
could swap lives with somebody like this
what would that do for you if you
actually could just say okay you are now
going to live this person's life for a
month complete priority change yeah
you'd be like I am never buying
Starbucks again you know what I mean
yeah you would yeah exactly you'd be
like I'm using all the extra resources
that I waste on my own FR fress I've
I've often done that that very thing I'm
you you know I'm driving down the road
in one of these countries and I'm like
what if I switch with that person right
now what would my life be like that
person riding the bike right now or
walking along the street what would be
different yeah and the real everything
everything would be different right yeah
MH how can parents talk to their kids
about this or how can um a family
provide a a safe environment for their
Community or their church family seeing
that this can happen at a drop of a hat
this type of exploitation
yeah I I look at it and say you know in
America probably we are more vulnerable
to child
abuse and I you know it's it's not the
same it's but it's you know the the
stats are are staggering you know one in
four girls before age 18 one and five
boys are abused and usually it's by a
family member and so certainly I think
that's something that is somewhat
related but something that we have as a
greater vulnerability here I do find
that parents here in the States want
their kids to have some level of
awareness I do my best to kind of do a
PG PG-13 version when I share with
families because we do have young
children that are in the audience when I
share but I've also found that parents
have appreciated their kids knowing
that you know this is a broken world
yeah and not everybody is safe and can
be trusted but I think where we really
let our guard down and where we've
really messed up I think even sometimes
as a church Community is our sympathies
go to the perpetrator who claims that
they're sorry who claims it'll never
happen again and mo most perpetrators
have multiple victims and 20% of
perpetrators have between 10 and 40
victims oh wow and so we need to really
be vigilant whether it's with human
trafficking or whether it's with child
abuse we have a
responsibility and you know I think of
Revelation 1813 where it talks about all
these items that the merchants of the
Earth Earth purchase and it ends by
saying that they purchased the body and
Souls of men and so that's the reality
of the world that we live in and so you
know my wife would always you know when
our kids were young and they would go to
use the restroom she would have her foot
with the door open to say are you okay
everything okay in there and I think as
parents we need to have that both from a
trafficking perspective but you know
probably primarily from a child abuse
perspective that we need to be really
making sure our kids are safe and that
they know how to how to find safety if
they're in a compromised situation amen
excellent we also work with baby rescue
baby's the most vulnerable of any human
being abely and so they get abandoned
for different reasons this boy was born
to a child bride who died in child birth
that's a high risk of child marriage wow
but the baby survived the baby survived
and it's it's a risk to the mom and to
the child I mean there's because they're
just too young or it's just that you
know a young mom doesn't necessarily
have all the skills to take care of this
baby and the Bab you know it's young
we're talking 13 13 15 you know you know
years of age and so the father because
he he was superstitious felt that this
this boy was bad luck so he left him
laying in a Hut by the body of his
deceased mom wow and so one of our
teachers found out about that and she
she was an orphan herself raised in the
home of missionaries and so she's
adopted him and she didn't have the
funds to do that so child impact helped
her with that adoption process you know
here's another boy that we res rescued
uh he was abandoned outside of a of a
home in this is in Tanzania this lady
heard him crying outside of her home
there took him to the hospital uh got a
hold of Social Services and he was taken
to one of our projects so this is him 8
months later soet so you can tell you
know he's flourishing healthy baby and
so we've even before I started with
child impact and before we partner with
this this particular project they had a
baby that was buried alive in a
graveyard and a Shepherd found him oh my
and so but they're in a region where
there's a lot of prostitution because of
Tourism and so a prostitute will get
pregnant and 9 months later you see
abandoned babies in toilets um out house
toilets in the market beside the road um
or a mom dies in child birth and you've
got these abandoned babies so right now
this particular project has over 30
babies um in addition to the children
that we work work with there so we're
the primary support financially for that
project wow what do you do with the
babies by the way I mean are you do you
send them into adoption programs
or it depends on the project um in this
particular project they will likely be
raised there they have a family setting
all of the they have eight homes in a
circle and all those homes have who they
what they call Mamas and so these babies
grow up with women that they know and
trust in a safe place kind of like a
daycare nurs well it's that's their home
that's where they live and so the goal
is that some at some point they'll grow
up and be independent and be able to
carry on with their own lives we have a
girl there that is part of our
sponsorship program who tested the very
top in the whole country of Tanzania
three years in a row wow and she's part
of a group of abandoned siblings wow and
so these kids have huge potential if
they're given the opportunity right
right this may be a difficult question
to answer um
there are situations where there
organizations that start off amazing
they do so much good but unfortunately
the people that work within them
actually fall prey to the thing that
they're trying to prevent and we even
see right now with the project
Underground Railroad I believe there's
there's some corruption happening there
so when people they have finances that
they want to pour into organizations how
can they vet these or organizations um
and and trust them yeah trust them and
well this is is a twofold question so it
it's them how how do people vet
organizations but also people who are
involved how do you protect yourself
against so much darkness and evil and to
for it not to infiltrate your own mind
and and mess with
that great questions um there are a
couple of organizations that
evaluate um nonprofits so uh charity
Navigator guar you can go to those
places and you can see what percentage
of funds actually go to the projects you
know do they have good accounting
practices all these kind of things so
we're always happy at child impact to
answer those questions and you know we
have an incredible board of directors
that ultimately oversees everything we
do we're audited you know all those
things you have to do business well as
you're doing Ministry absolutely and so
super important because you know with
any of us trust can be lost in a moment
and it's hard to regain and so we want
to make sure that we're aboveboard and
trustworthy in everything that we do and
we've said no to projects that don't uh
line up I went to one country and almost
everything the person told me was not
true wow wow and there are organizations
that don't even visit their projects and
don't don't vet them there's a cost to
doing that but we feel like there's a
responsibility and accountability with
donor dollars that we're making sure
that they go to the intended place and
that they're being used properly so
that's not free to do we had a donor one
time wanted to bypass child impact and
just give directly the project a year
later they came back and said by the way
can we send our funds through you
because we like how you do things wow so
yeah it's there's a cost to it we keep
it to the as low of percentage as
possible because we want to help the
kids with everything we can I think
that's super important and I think
there's probably a lot of people out
there that have this kind of mindset as
well it actually has prevented me in the
past of supporting children in you know
like you know get a sponsor and stuff
like this because I've heard these T
stories people of what they do with the
money like 10 cents out of every 20
bucks makes it to the kid yeah and and
so I I actually would love it if we
could put the link down there to some of
these ways that that that people could
uh trust and and and pick through that I
think that's very important so if you
sponsor an impoverished child a
vulnerable child through child impact
85% of what you give will go to support
that child that's beautiful you know
it's I wish 100% could go but the
reality is the world we live
there has to be accountability process
and you know we travel to share the
stories to you know you know people give
based on knowing that is changing lives
and so that's a story we need to share
and so but I always get the most
economical ticket I can get and plan
plan ahead and we stay with our projects
they feed us at our projects so there's
things you can do you don't have to live
a high lifestyle when you're going to do
these things you can you can be humble
in the way that you approach things
right and and go about Ministry so right
you know we're in a we're in a rented
space with child impact it's uh it's on
the campus of Southern Aven University
which is great beautiful because we can
get student volunteers we can get
student workers that are come at a lower
price and we can get student interns
that are required to put a certain am
amount of hours in so we have cost
savings even by being on the campus
there and so these are things that we
have to weigh and look at in terms of
how we manage but you asked a second
question how does a person protect
themselves when I was a young boy uh
there were some friends up in a tree
that wanted me to come up and look at
pornography and I said no and you know
from that point in my life I realized
that you know we can exploit women girls
in ways that demeans them as a human
being and I did not want to be a part of
that and yet we know as men that we're
drawn to these images and so we have to
stay away from things that tap into that
side of our carnality right and so
that's a purposeful decision that we
have to make and I've I've really always
leaned heavily on a verse that says be
careful when you think you stand lest
you fall none of us should be thinking
that we're above Temptation or we're
above that vulnerability and so I try to
always travel with other people from my
team I take my wife with me whenever I
can and I don't need to watch or view
the things to know the evil that's there
right and so you know we need to stay
clear of that because I think it's it's
something that can easily IL suck a
person in MH to where they get trapped
by it and the very thing you're trying
to save people from you can become
consumed by yourself yeah and so that's
a vigilance that all of us need to have
in our own lives and it's it's a
constant battle that we need to to be
aware of and and make sure that we're
not only holding ourselves accountable
but allowing other people to hold us
accountable too so so did you give those
boys up in the tree a Bible Lesson like
let me let me tell you about another
tree where somebody tried to entice them
into this uh Genesis
wow well yeah know it's it's certainly a
challenge in the world that we live in
isn't it and we know we know it's
it's and and and I think that technology
has really fed into all of that because
you know when we were kids there's a
level of embarrassment you got to climb
up into the tree you know you have to
like somehow get a hold of a magazine
this stuff comes to everybody's phone
now I mean I mean kids can look at it
with such ease today it's it's really
mindboggling they don't even have to
look for it it pops up as that's right
you don't even have to se yeah it's
accidentally being put in front of you
or not accidentally well and one out of
five children that are on the internet
will be approached by somebody who is
wanting to engage with them sexually
social media so yeah it's just so that's
just one and five kids are going to be
what wherever they're going they're
going to they're going to come across
stuff that entices them that way you
want to see a documentary that will
really freak you out about what's on the
internet childhood 2.0 I think you can
watch it on YouTube yeah I had a
question you said uh that you're on the
campus and you have some volunteer jobs
what would that look like if a student
says I want to help what are they going
to do with you yeah so because there's a
certain level of training that's
involved we tend to take volunteers that
are consistent and can come in every
week there are occasions where we'll
have somebody come in and you know stuff
envelopes you know put addresses on some
of these kind of things so some of the
the basic work that way but we do have
roles where we have regular volunteers
that come in and we'll work four hours a
week or 6 hours a week with child impact
and uh there's a training that we go
through for that because we have a
database that you they'll they'll need
to access to do some data entry kind of
things for us and we have profiles that
we print of of children that we take to
our events and to help us prepare for
events so we have a student intern this
summer that's working with us fulltime
AES every hour that every hour we're
open he's there and he's out preaching
on the weekends as well and so he's
getting a great internship and it's a
huge blessing to us and so now you have
a big date coming up here pretty soon um
yes what what is this date and how can
people get involved and help you even in
this rush hour yes so July 30 is the
world day against human trafficking and
so it's a big day where awareness is
raised and of course we hope to share
ways where that awareness can move into
action and so we have a big event every
year in this local area in the in the
Chattanooga College Dell area that we
run um we're going to happen we happen
to be tying it to our open house so July
27 I'll be preaching at a church College
Dell Community Church and that Saturday
evening uh we have a program where we
talk about our projects including we'll
go off camera and talk about our secret
projects so that's at 5:00 on the 27th
of July and then on the 28th from 10:00
to 4: we're doing a child impact open
house on the campus of Southern right as
you drive into Southern's campus we're
right on the left hand side there in the
Fleming Plaza so that's local but we're
producing a video related to our project
for this year which is to build a safe
house in the Philippines for kids that
are in the highlands that are vulnerable
to child marriage so they can come down
into the lowlands and have a place to
stay to pursue their studies so this is
what the girls want they get trapped
from pressure from their family or from
the boy to get married at a young age
but I've met with these girls and they
want to pursue their education they have
dreams for their lives and so we have 14
acres of land that we've secured and now
we're going to build out some
infrastructure there so that's what
we're raising funds for for the July 30
uh Focus this year and so this is the
first video in a series uh about
that Palawan has been ranked the number
one island in the world yet here on this
magnificent Island there's some
inequities that are taking place and
many of their Customs are still carried
on including child marriage and child
Brides there is a culture here in in the
mountains where their parents are the
ones making the decision for them we
should already be married at around 12
years old it's a it's almost a forced
marriage it's like they see and think
that this is all I am I lost hope of
being able to continue my studies
there's like a sparkle gone out of their
eyes that happens all the
time it's heartbreaking but to see these
kids getting their certificate that
they're proceeding to the next level and
for them to gain their dignity that is
such a wonderful
gift if our audience would like to learn
more about child impact or donate to the
ministry like how can how can they stay
informed about what you're doing and and
keep up to date awesome so we have a
magazine uh that we send out uh once
every five well five a year so five
copies a year um this is also available
online it just some amazing news it so
happens that our photographer has been
featured by National Geographic Jasper
tiyaga cool yeah J yeah he's amazing so
he's full-time with child impact he
travels with me all the time um but just
amazing magazine great photos great
stories um and so that's available on
our website as well we send out a Friday
Field Report so anybody that provides
their email to us uh we send out a
Friday update every week um for those
that participate with our operation
child rescue as part of the rescue party
there's a special monthly operation
child rescue report about our rescue
projects so these are ways to stay aware
uh to take action you can do that on our
website child impact.org and in this
context select operation child rescue
and become either a onetime or monthly
donor for that also would love for you
to stop by in our office we' love to
give tours and awesome and share our
stories cool I want to come to your
event yeah oh that'd be amazing for sure
me too you know I was reading Mark chap
10 and in there Jesus himself he says
that the kingdom of God belongs to who
the children yes little children and so
that's one of the reasons I believe that
the devil is working so hard to cause
harm to Little Children uh through
whether it is through exploitation or
through ideologies that we're seeing
rise up in this country worldwide really
and or wiping them out completely which
is the most heart-wrenching thing that
can happen as Christ ambassadors it is
our duty to protect children the best
way we know how through the help of
Jesus Christ and so Tom I want to thank
you so much for opening our eyes to
what's happening out there but also
giving us tips on how to practically get
involved I just want to encourage our
viewing
audience the Lord does encourage us to
take action it's always good to have the
biblical knowledge but it's not until we
actually Implement that knowledge that
we're living out our Christianity and so
I want to thank you so much for watching
I hope you were blessed I hope uh you
know the the IDE ideas are are flowing
through your mind and that you're
actually going to put them into action
uh if you're new here please subscribe
and you know a free way to help out this
ministry little life Studios is to leave
a like and to share it with a friend so
we ask that you do that for those who
would like to help us uh financially
there are links in the description for
where you can donate to us or you can
check out our lightwear uh designs I'm
actually wearing a t-shirt now so is
Scotty and there are so many other
designs on there not just in teachers
form but in stickers if you want to
throw on a laptop or on a water bottle
we have free wallpapers as well on our
website little light studios. TV so all
of that is available for you all to
check out we've been posting podcast
episodes on YouTube but if you don't
want to wait week after week for those
episodes you can check out the little
light Studios podcast on all podcasting
platforms season 1 is fully out there
and we're rolling out season two
actually as we speak right now so you
can go and check that out if you're
interested
uh and yeah we just want to thank you so
much again for watching and we hope we
have a blessed day we'll see you next
time on LED bye-bye
[Music]
Jacob and he you for you
Israel pill in the temple of my God and
he shall go out no more I will ride on
him the name of my
God strength
shall shall
I pray alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of
God do you have questions about the
Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your journey
I'm sorry do we know each other it seems
like maybe we've met before I don't know
this is uh it's awkward though just as
much for me as it is for you I really
wish I had a conversation
starter oh hey oh what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]
oh